-Qui est pour ?
Qui est contre ?
-La séance est levée.
Générique
...
-Je suis Lisa Belluco,
députée écologiste de la Vienne.
On est à côté
de ma circonscription
pour vous montrer
ces méga-bassines,
derrière moi.
Ce sont des réserves de substitution
pour l'agriculture
et pour l'irrigation, en été,
quand il y a des sécheresses.
C'est ce que je ne veux pas voir
se développer dans mon département.
-Des millions de mètres cubes d'eau
dans lesquels les agriculteurs
puisent pour arroser
leurs cultures,
principalement du maïs,
très gourmand en eau.
Dans la Vienne,
un protocole vient d'autoriser
la création de 30 nouvelles réserves
comme celle-ci, dont une partie
sur la circonscription
de Lisa Belluco.
Elles permettront
de prélever en hiver
près de 9 millions de mètres cubes
dans les nappes phréatiques.
Une hérésie,
pour la députée écologiste.
-On a l'idée
que nos nappes phréatiques
sont trop remplies en hiver,
du coup, on veut pomper
dans les nappes phréatiques
pour remplir ces bassines
pour utiliser l'eau l'été
et pour moins consommer d'eau l'été
ou pouvoir arroser
même s'il y a une sécheresse.
Là où ça marche pas,
c'est que nos nappes phréatiques
ne sont pas en surplus l'hiver.
Pour l'instant, on ne peut
pas remplir les bassines
et c'est ce qui risque
de se reproduire.
Mon rôle,
c'est d'en parler, de poser
des questions aux ministres,
de mettre à l'agenda du gouvernement
ce sujet des méga-bassines,
qui n'était pas un sujet
jusqu'à maintenant.
Musique folk
-La bataille de l'eau
a déjà commencé
dans le département.
Les sécheresses
s'intensifient et les cours d'eau
sont plus bas que jamais.
-Il y a eu
des choléra E.coli
qui se reproduisaient.
-La moitié des rivières de la Vienne
est quasiment à sec.
C'est le cas de La Pallu,
au nord de Poitiers.
-On est en train
de regarder le désastre.
D'habitude, ici,
on devrait avoir
4 à 5 mètres d'eau,
mais aujourd'hui,
il n'y a plus rien.
Cette rivière fait 30 km,
elle est complètement
asséchée.
...
Vous voyez
cette même rivière avec l'eau qui
devrait y avoir normalement dedans,
et ça avait été photographié
le 7 septembre 2013.
Et voyez ce qu'on a vu cet été.
Voilà nos belles truites,
nos poissons.
Voilà des truites,
des goujons, des vairons,
et voilà le résultat.
On a chiffré
le préjudice écologique.
Rien qu'en mortalité de poissons,
on est à plus de 5 millions d'euros.
-OK.
-On va les voir de plus près.
-Les truites farios
ont totalement disparu
de La Pallu.
Trop de dérogations,
trop de pompage dans les eaux...
La rivière n'a pas résisté.
Musique pesante
...
-Vous voyez, là.
C'est pas acceptable de voir
qu'il n'y a plus d'eau.
Normalement,
l'eau devrait arriver ici.
Il n'y a plus rien.
Donc voilà.
Complètement à sec.
La Pallu traverse la zone
certainement la plus influencée
par les prélèvements agricoles.
C'est là qu'on va rencontrer
le plus d'irrigation
en plein été.
-Parce que dans ce secteur,
c'est des grandes cultures,
des céréales, du maïs.
-Souvent des grosses
propriétés céréalières.
-On a plus d'eau
sur certaines années
qui est envoyée sur les cultures
que d'eau dans la rivière,
pour vous montrer
l'ampleur du déséquilibre
au niveau de l'usage
de la ressource.
-On consacre plus d'eau à irriguer
qu'on en laisse dans la rivière.
-Exactement.
-Et selon eux,
les cinq méga-bassines
en projet dans le secteur
n'arrangeront pas
la situation.
Au pied de La Pallu à sec,
Lisa Belluco
a donc trouvé
un allier inattendu.
-C'est vrai
qu'on se connaissait pas
avant de se rencontrer
sur la situation
des réserves de substitution,
et on n'est pas
des alliés naturels,
ce qui est idiot parce que
les meilleurs connaisseurs
des milieux aquatiques
sont les pêcheurs.
En face, les irrigants
sont très forts
et ont l'oreille du préfet,
mais on voit
que les pêcheurs aussi,
alors que les associations
environnementales,
sur ces questions, on dit :
"C'est les écolos, c'est bon."
Quand il y a la fédération
de pêche qui dit :
"Moi non plus,
je suis pas d'accord,"
ça permet de jouer un peu
à armes égales face aux irrigants.
-On est des lanceurs d'alertes.
Lorsqu'il y a de l'eau
dans les rivières,
il y a de l'eau potable aussi.
Et si on n'a pas
de recharges hivernales,
on va boire je sais pas quoi
l'année prochaine.
-Comme les pêcheurs,
la députée écologiste
a refusé de signer
le protocole d'accords
des 30 réserves
du bassin du Clain.
Mais elle va devoir composer
avec les agriculteurs
irrigants
de son département.
-Donc là ?
-On est sur une partie
de l'exploitation,
sur un des îlots principaux,
qui lui est irrigué.
Donc sur la gauche,
une parcelle de blé
qui était en maïs l'an dernier.
On est dans les rotations.
Et sur l'autre partie,
qui est aujourd'hui en herbe,
on est avec des couverts végétaux
qui vont normalement permettre
de porter les parcelles de maïs,
si, bien sûr,
nous avons l'eau nécessaire
à son implantation.
-Olivier Pin, maraîcher
et producteur de maïs semences,
est aussi le président
des irrigants de la Vienne.
Comme beaucoup, il dispose
de dérogations préfectorales
de prélèvements d'eau
pour irriguer ses champs.
-Pour moi, l'eau vient directement
de la rivière.
Je suis un des derniers préleveurs
rivière historiques
dans le secteur.
-Mais aujourd'hui,
c'est insuffisant,
et il craint de ne plus
pouvoir honorer
ses contrats de vente,
avec sa coopérative.
-On continue
pour le moment à avoir
ces contrats,
mais si demain,
on n'a pas une ressource
qui est validée et stockée,
nous ne les aurons plus.
-Son seul espoir,
une retenue d'eau
à laquelle
il sera bientôt raccordé.
-Votre réserve de substitution
sera sur cette parcelle ?
-Donc a priori,
les plans qu'on a conçus
sont sur cette parcelle-là,
effectivement, qui fait
entre 6 et 7 hectares.
-208 000 mètres cubes d'eau
partagés entre quatre agriculteurs
aux alentours,
l'équivalent
de 55 piscines olympiques.
Le protocole prévoit
de raccorder 153 exploitations,
raccordement
en partie financé
par l'Etat, alors qu'il y a
2000 agriculteurs sur le bassin.
Lisa Belluco dénonce
cette appropriation de l'eau.
-Ca concerne
très peu d'agriculteurs ?
-Mais ça concerne des agriculteurs
sur des secteurs
qui sont hyper vulnérables.
-C'est un accaparement,
- le mot est dur - de l'eau
pour quelques-uns au début,
et après, j'entends
qu'on puisse connecter
d'autres personnes,
que ça puisse être étendu,
mais le projet,
c'est pas ça.
Je reproche que la logique
soit faite à partir des besoins
et pas à partir
de l'eau disponible.
J'ai peur qu'il n'y ait pas
assez d'eau,
et vous serez les premiers
à en pâtir, en fait.
-De toute façon, si on n'a pas
d'eau, on ne sera plus là.
-Je dis pas que retenir l'eau,
c'est une mauvaise idée.
Je dis qu'à cette échelle
et avec ces volumes,
ça me semble une mauvaise idée
parce qu'on est dans une phase
de changement climatique
et qu'on risque...
On sait qu'on aura moins d'eau.
-Le partage équitable de l'eau,
la députée en est convaincue,
ne pourra se faire
qu'avec une agritulture
moins gourmande, plus raisonnée.
C'est aussi le combat
de la confédération paysanne.
-BONJOUR.
-Le syndicat agricole a convié
les quatre députés du département.
Seuls Lisa Belluco
et Pascal Lecamp
ont accepté.
Lui est député MoDem
et il défend les réserves d'eau.
-On va aller
faire une visite, Tony,
emmène-nous.
-Sur les terres de cet éleveur
d'agneaux en herbe,
sans irrigation,
le débat entre pros
et antis-bassines
s'engage rapidement.
-On a deux positions
qui pourraient s'entendre.
Je suis convaincue
qu'à la fin de cette rencontre,
il aura un autre avis
sur la situation.
-Moi, je parle à tout le monde,
et je connais le dossier.
Les réserves, c'est pour combien
de millions de mètres cubes ?
-8,9.
-Oh là là.
T'as travaillé,
depuis la dernière fois.
-Ces exploitants ont fait le choix
d'une agriculture moins intensive,
plus respectueuse des sols,
selon eux.
Auprès des parlementaires,
ils cherchent un appui
pour une meilleure utilisation
de l'eau.
-C'est ça, c'est pour remplir
le Ricard, les bassines, en fait.
Musique douce
...
-L'irrigation,
certaines productions
doivent être priorisées,
le maraichage, l'arboriculture,
voire l'élevage,
la production de semences,
mais faire des bassines
pour produire du maïs
qui va aller
soit à Lapalisse pour être exporté
soit dans un méthaniseur
pour produire de l'énergie,
ça pose problème.
-Il faut faire un travail
agronomique sur l'amélioration
des sols et sur le stockage
de l'eau de pluie dans les sols
et faire d'autres cultures.
-Je suis pas technicien,
mais il y a sans doute
une solution.
-C'est ce qui consomme le plus d'eau
quand il n'y en a plus.
Même s'il y en a moins...
-Il faudra peut-être
arrêter un jour le maïs.
-Aujourd'hui,
ils demandent de l'eau
à travers des bassines.
On leur dit :
"On va financer."
Je suis en vente directe...
-Mais en échange
de cet accès à l'eau,
les irrigants
s'engagent à replanter
des haies,
préserver les milieux aquatiques
et diminuer de moitié
l'utilisation
des pesticides.
L'Etat promet
de contrôler,
mais ce ne sera pas si simple.
-A la session vendredi dernier,
un agriculteur a dit :
"Les contreparties,
"je les respecterai pas."
Publiquement.
-Face aux méga bassines,
ce sont en réalité deux mondes
agricoles qui s'affrontent
et qui cherchent des compromis.
-Il faut se mettre
autour d'une table et se parler.
On est des facilitateurs,
les députés.
On n'a plus
de réserve parlementaire
pour mettre de l'argent
sur la table.
-Le préfet s'appuie aussi
sur les parlementaires
pour avoir des retours de terrain,
sur les élus locaux,
sur un tas de personnes.
Si on a des parlementaires
qui pensent pas tous pareil,
ça change la configuration du débat,
ça l'alimente.
-Pour défendre sa cause,
la députée n'a pas hésité
à se joindre à un rassemblement
interdit.
C'était fin octobre,
sur le chantier de la méga bassine
de Sainte-Soline,
dans le département voisin.
Lisa Belluco était
dans le cortège des élus,
aux premières loges,
face aux gendarmes,
lorsque la manifestation d'opposants
a tourné court.
-Laissez-moi !
-Lisa Belluco a depuis dénoncé
les coups des gendarmes
et porté plainte pour violences.
-Quand une élue se fait frapper
par des gendarmes,
on peut s'imaginer que le ministre
de l'Intérieur lui envoie un mot.
Ce ministre de l'Intérieur
dit que je suis une terroriste.
Je sais pas dans quel monde on est,
mais c'est un monde qui va pas bien.
C'est pas possible de faire ça.
Moi, je crois que là,
si ça continue comme ça,
on est entré
dans une guerre de l'eau.
Le gouvernement, ce gouvernement,
a déclenché une guerre de l'eau.
-Dans son département,
Lisa Belluco va devoir affronter
trois députés de la majorité
favorables au projet.
Pour elle, la guerre de l'eau
ne fait que commencer.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Musique folk
...